pékin consécration du nouveau maître de
la chine wako fang deuxième journée des
évêques troublé par les traditionalistes
jean lecanuet antenne 2 priorité à la
lutte contre l'inflation
pour la dernière course à longchamp
tiercé de favori à quoi servent les
chambres de commerce demain élection des
nouveaux responsables
elle amusée messieurs bonsoir le
président hu à waco feng le successeur
de no tsé toung a reçu aujourd'hui à
pékin sur la place tiananmen
une consécration officielle et populaire
bien digne de la tradition chinoise un
million de personnes une organisation
époustouflante et pour nous français
quelques heures après l'événement ce qui
est tout à fait inhabituelle des images
pas excellente
allez le constater car elles ont été
transmises via hong kong dans des
conditions difficiles mais des images
tout de même exceptionnel
y'a pas grand chose ou s'ils répondent à
un chômage
bien humain au château devenu mao
aujourd'hui il n'y a alors fait déjà on
l'appelle mois
cris
la chine a donc un nouveau leader et un
million de personnes à pékin atteleyn wa
de ce wpt à coiffer n'y premier ministre
du parti communiste chinois
première apparition publique du
président pour une manifestation de 80
minutes
le groupe des 4 dont la veuve de mao a
été condamné et revêtues de l'uniforme
de l'art de l'armée chinoise comme mao
wako fine comme mao sable la petite
l'église l'église à nouveau sur la
sellette en ce dimanche avec l'assemblée
épiscopale de lourdes le sondage de
l'hebdomadaire chrétien la vie et une
conférence de presse de monseigneur
lefebvre en allemagne après une messe
intégristes le sondage de la vie réalisé
par l'ifop auprès de 2000 chrétiens
indique que 63 % des personnes
interrogées jugent qu'il est
indispensable d'aller à la messe tous
les dimanches et que 63 % sont
favorables à la messe en français
pas de commentaire à lourdes sur ces
chiffres mais une vive réaction des
intégristes c'est à dire des partisans
de monseigneur lefebvre l'assemblée
plénière des évêques de france dans cet
endroit vous et à la prière au
pèlerinage aux méditations de
l'épiscopat français
on a vu aujourd'hui des manifestations
d'hostilité tout près de la grotte de
bernadette soubirous l'offensive
intégristes bat son plein en ce moment
dans les rues de lourdes on distribue un
peu partout des revues et des tracts qui
met en cause les orientations de
l'épiscopat français non seulement en
matière religieuse mais aussi sur le
plan politique on accuse les évêques de
faciliter l'arrivée du communisme en
france on les accuse aussi de se taire
sur les grands problèmes du moment
avortement évolution des moeurs etc
une délégation a même fait un peu de
forcing tout à l'heure pour être reçu
par l'assemblée plénière plus hormis ce
qui je crois orienté beaucoup mon père
aurait fait alors voilà le premier
championnat
le père fille et ne reçoit pas les
injures je tire à dire qu'il n'ya là
dedans aucune injure ya seulement un
document qui n'est absolument pas un
document de supplique nous n'avons rien
demandé si nous avions quelque chose à
demander
nous ne savions pas à qui le demande et
donc nous avons tout simplement voulu
faire un texte que nous remettons
aujourd'hui solennellement à nos évêques
qu'ils le prennent ou qui ne le prennent
pas nous importe peu
mais dans ce texte nous disons que de la
résistance nous sommes passés à
l'offensive
les évêques ne semble pas prendre trop
tragique cette campagne contre ou plus
exactement contre l'église du concile il
travaille portes fermées après avoir
célébré en fin de matinée une messe
solennelle
néanmoins en se réunissant aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'entre eux ne pourront
s'empêcher de penser qu'une autre messe
interdite celle là était célébré ce
matin en allemagne par monseigneur le
faire plusieurs centaines de personnes y
assistaient autour du prélat intégriste
c'est dire que jobs de force monseigneur
lefebvre est bel et bien présent ici à
lourdes en cette assemblée plénière 1976
pratiquement à la même heure monseigneur
le père célébré ce dimanche une messe
traditionalistes afridi
devant près de 7000 personnes auparavant
le prélat suspendu a divinis avait dans
une conférence de presse violemment
attaqué les communistes avant de mettre
en cause le représentant du pape à la
conférence d'helsinki et d'accuser le
vatican ii cultivé depuis cette
conférence des relations avec l'union
soviétique
monseigneur lefebvre a d'autre part
réaffirmé ses options traditionalistes
et indiqué que la récente lettre que lui
a adressée pool6 lui demandant de
réintégrer l'église conciliaire
constituait à ses yeux un refus total de
continuer la tradition
autant beau temps fixe ciel bleu et
sérénité au comité central de lui des
airs qui étaient réunis aujourd'hui à
boulogne billancourt apparemment toutes
les petites phrases les déclarations les
interviews qui anime actuellement la vie
politique n'ont pas eu beaucoup
d'emprise sur les leaders du mouvement
gaulliste qui attendaient surtout
aujourd'hui la déclaration de jacques
chirac y est bien cette déclaration
attendue a été entendu puisque sans
grande difficulté sans beaucoup de
discussions la motion que propose l
ancien premier ministre que vous ouvrez
les en ce moment pour une certaine
relance de lui des airs et même une
transformation du mouvement a été adopté
à l'unanimité
monsieur chaban delmas lui même s'est
finalement rallié à la proposition de
transformation de lutter non sans
exprimer quelques craintes
le problème est de savoir maintenant si
l'ancien premier ministre réussira ou
non sur les bases qui s'est fixé à
réunir autour de sa personne et de sa
plate-forme les français que le temps ni
la gauche ni la majorité des cas telle
qu'elle se présente
bref il lui restera ensuite à voir
comment ceux qui appartiennent déjà à la
majorité présidentielle pourront avoir
également un pied dans son ensemble m
s'il réussit cette périlleuse opération
il est bien certain qu'il assurera à lui
d r non seulement sa survie mais aussi
au rassemblement dont il sera le leader
une place prépondérante dans la majorité
de 2 mai à prendre trop de place
hors de lui dr monsieur chirac même
s'ils ne le souhaitent pas sincèrement
ne risque-t-il pas une nouvelle fois de
se dresser face au président de la
république
en tout cas dans la majorité
présidentielle on suit avec beaucoup
d'attention l'activité fébrile du
mouvement gaulliste en particulier du
côté des centristes du cds selon jacques
barrot le secrétaire général des
démocrates sociaux on est bien d'accord
pour que jacques chirac engage son
mouvement dans une action de masse à
condition que le rassemblement prônée
par jacques chirac soit parallèle à
celui du cds donc non perpendiculaire si
je puis dire c'est bien c'est bien
l'avis de jean lecanuet le président de
ce mouvement
jean le caennais qui s'explique que par
ailleurs ce soir pour antenne 2 sur la
petite phrase de françois mitterrand
extraite de la longue interview que le
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
accorde un pari
françois mitterrand qui qualifie jean
lecanuet de représentants de la pensée
la plus sclérosé de france mais avant
d'écouter la réponse sur ce point du
ministre d'état
une question monsieur jean lecanuet
après les déclarations du président de
la république que pensez vous pensez
vous qu'on est d'ores et déjà la pie et
longues prioritaire c'est l'action du
gouvernement c'est la lutte contre
l'inflation
simplement le président de la république
agissant d'ailleurs comme ses
prédécesseurs annonce que lorsque
l'échéance viendra en 78 il ne sera pas
passifs neutre il éclairera le choix des
français je trouve qu'il est là tout à
fait dans son rôle dans sa mission
il en a même le devoir nous ne sommes
pas en campagne électorale dit vous
n'avez vous des de relancer le débat en
disant du programme commun que c'était
une momie dont on n'osait pas des tirs
les bandelettes
oui j'ai dit que c'était une momie c'est
une image ne sais pas mais je crois
qu'elle qu'elle traduit bien ce qu'est
le programme commun il a été constitué
je crois par les communistes et les
socialistes voici quatre ans c'est à
dire avant le grand problème de la
hausse du pétrole et des matières
premières
bref il est là dans ces bandelettes
immobile personne n'ose y toucher et
monsieur me tran est bien obligé de
reconnaître le fait elle ne reconnaît
pas excusez moi il ne reconnaît pas
tellement puisque il vient de vous
répondre dans chez notre confrère paris
match en disant que monsieur les cas
j'essaierai comme celui vous
représentiez une pensée politique
sclérosé
oui je crois que les français ne seront
pas d'accord avec cette opinion mais
monsieur mitrand ne répond pas au fond
du problème
son programme commun et démodé il est
lui sclérosé les mêmes pétrifiée une
ministre
comment interpréter et l'action de
jacques chirac je crois comprendre
l'action de jacques chirac comme celle
d'un homme qui disposant maintenant de
tout son temps et c'est de renforcer son
parti qui représente depuis les
dernières élections présidentielles
semble-t-il environ
15 % de l'opinion française jacques
chirac s'adresse à la tradition
gaulliste
nous ne représentons une tradition de
démocratie sociale pour la j'ajoute pour
en terminer avec ce long chapitre
politique qui montre bien d'ailleurs que
décidément le débat préélectoral est
largement ouvert que l'on reparlera
cette semaine de la sphère d'assaut
puisque dès mardi jean-jacques
servan-schreiber reprendra sa
proposition sur les nationalisations
devant groupes réformateurs le sien donc
alors que georges séguy qui était ce
soir l'invité du club de la presse
d'europe 1 a annoncé que neuf
nationalisation prévus par le programme
commun la cgt en ajoutaient deux autres
le reste du secteur automobile donc
renault et le reste et la sidérurgie au
large de l'île de sein c'est toujours
l'incertitude sur les risques ce qui
subsiste ou non d'une marée noire plus
importante un sous marin de poche de la
marine nationale est prêt dès que les
conditions météo le permettront a plongé
pour aller inspecter les flancs du
pétrolier est allemand et voir si l'on
ne peut pas éventuellement colmater la
brèche sur place ou alors tenter de
renflouer le navire en attendant les
habitants de l'île et les sauveteurs
font leurs comptes et s'aperçoivent que
les moyens employés pour lutter contre
la marée noire était finalement
insuffisant dérisoire en fait ils n'ont
absolument pas évolué depuis la
catastrophe du torrey canyon et son
compte tenu des risques nouveaux due à
la construction des super tanker de
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
tonnes
largement insuffisant le risque
pollution n'est pas prêt de diminuer
dans l'avenir toutefois il est possible
qu'ils changent les pays producteurs de
pétrole raffiné de plus en plus chez eux
alors dans quelques années ce n'est pas
du mazout des produits lourds que l'on
transportera mais les produits légers
comme l'essence au risque pollution et
on va s'ajouter le risque incendie en
cas d'accident les militaires du
contingent armés de pelles et de
poubelles paraîtront encore plus
dérisoire dans la lutte anti pollution
que ce soit en france ou à l'étranger
tout reste à faire nous n'avons pas de
bateau ou véritablement spécialisés pour
cela et cette eau même une responsable
de la marine de lutter contre la
pollution au large et
dispose pour ce faire d'un certain
nombre d'équipements qui sont
normalement à terre et qu'on installe
très rapidement sur les bateaux qu'on
fait intervenir sur les nappes de
pétrole qu'on a décelé
mais ces moyens ne sont pas réellement
efficaces ou présentent de graves
inconvénients
ainsi les détergents sans parler de
leurs actions sur la faune et la flore
ne sont valables que pour certaine
densité de pétrole le plâtre précipite
ce mazout au fond de la mer mais là
encore le milieu marin est touché il
existe bien des systèmes d'aspiration du
pétrole comme le vortex ou le cyclone et
mais ce type de matériel a été prévu
pour fonctionner dans les ports en eaux
calmes et c'est hélas rarement par temps
calme que se produisent des catastrophes
il y est enfin des barrages flottants
pour protéger des endroits très
localisés mais là aussi l'état de la mer
les vents et les courants peuvent les
rendre inutilisables du problème de
pollution ont été pris au sérieux aussi
bien par les pétroliers à l'epo gras
public
mais s'il existe une étude à mon sens
elle existe dans le fait qu'elles n'ont
pas été pris en considération la part
tant ses moyens financiers et la source
de financement pour supporter une telle
action c'est là et tient le poids et
critique de la faire j'estime vivre une
dizaine d'années avec l'expérience vécue
au cours de sinistres successifs pour
créer développer à mesure des voyagistes
en développer de nouveaux moyens faire
converger l'imagination et l'expérience
pour que dans une dizaine d'années on
dispose de d'équipement diversifié
répondants nécessité aux différents
niveaux d'intervention
l'amiral clientes précise encore si l'on
se donne les moyens dans cette lutte
anti pollution
il faudra deux ans pour atteindre de 15
à 50 % d'efficacité
après dix ans cette efficacité
approchera 90%
en attendant à l'île de sein c'est la
grande marée du week-end qui fera sans
doute l'essentiel du nettoyage une
chance pour les pêcheurs bretons ces
marais qui malheureusement n'existe pas
surtout notre littoral
le voile se lève ce soir sur le
volumineux rapport de la commission
guichard 500 pages remise par le
ministre de la justice au président de
la république pour une réforme
fondamentale des collectivités locales
qui doit se traduire en particulier par
une décentralisation accrue des
compétences et des responsabilités au
profit au profit des maires et des élus
locaux c'est d'une réforme de longue
haleine qui sera mise en oeuvre sur
plusieurs ennemis j'amène mon apport
vendredi donc ça pas très vieux le
président a un public à la salle de
faire étudier par le gouvernement après
quoi on pourrait envisager un texte
législatif ce n'est pas la possible
prochaine et ensuite je pense qu'il
faudra en tout sept ou huit ans pour
arriver à mettre sur pied la première
étape de la forme de sport
rien ne sera donc fait avant les
municipales non parce que non pas dans
votre initiative
peut-être simplement certaines mesures
écart-là réglementaires pourraient être
décidées par le gouvernement avant la
fin d'année
demain au caire s'ouvre le sommet arabe
doit concrétiser l'accord de
cessez-le-feu signé arias de la semaine
dernière entre les syriens les
palestiniens à la gauche et la droite
libanaise le chef mahmoud ryad le
secrétaire général de la ligue arabe
s'entretient avec le général égyptien
chargé du respect du cessez-le-feu sur
le terrain toujours des victimes avaient
l'accalmie les échanges pour avic ont
toujours lieu entre phalangistes et
palestiniens dans le sud du pays à la
frontière avec israël
nous venons à genève pour mettre sur
pied un gouvernement de transition et
non pour élaborer un règlement pacifique
c'est ce qu'a déclaré à son arrivée à
genève le leader africain en lutte
contre la rhodésie de monsieur jan smith
les délégués africains ont également
affirmé que la guérilla se
poursuivraient en rhodésie tant que le
pouvoir ne sera pas totalement transféré
à la majorité loi pour le ministre
rhodésien blanc des affaires étrangères
le plan kissinger doit s'appliquer dans
son ensemble une négociation difficile
la saison des courses de galop à
longchamp s'est terminée par une
surprise pour les parieurs surprise de
voir trois des favoris à l'arrivée ce
qui s'était pas produit depuis plusieurs
semaines au moins que l'on puisse dire
en effet que la saison d'été de
longchamp a été marquée par une série de
victoires inattendues les spécialistes
d'où une série le beau tiercé
bien entendu ce ne sera pas le cas
aujourd'hui puisque le numéro 3 à mr le
numéro 7 me rassis et le numéro 2 far
off les favoris étaient à l'arrivée à
partir de dimanche prochain
tiercé dans les courses d'obstacles à
auteuil
mais avant le départ du tiercé les
jockeys les entraîneurs et le public a
fait observer une minute de silence à la
mémoire de daniel merle
les médecins n'ont pu sauver le jockey
gravement blessé vendredi sur
l'hippodrome d'enghien au cours d'une
chute dans la rivière des tribunes
daniel merle avait 29 ans il était très
connu du public très aimé en particulier
depuis sa victoire dans la grande course
de haies d'auteuil mois de juin dernier
c'est donc que jameson qui est devenu
officiellement champion du monde de
formule 1 le coureur automobile n'a pas
remporté la dernière épreuve le grand
prix du japon
mais l'abandon après le premier tour de
niki lauda lui a ouvert le chemin du
titre mondial bien méritée nul ne
contestera mais que de ma chance cette
année pour niki lauda 4816 7,69 un telle
est la solution chiffré du championnat
du monde des conducteurs
c'est à dire en clair 4800 km de course
décomposé en 16 grands prix pour cette
victoire représentant 69 points soit un
point seulement de plus que le deuxième
niki lauda james hunt en se classant
troisième du grand prix du japon
derrière andretti et de payet a donc
battu sur le fil lauda est à 29 ans il
remporte son premier jeu ne peut pas
contester les qualités de pilote de hunt
il n'en reste pas moins que l'on
regrettera la façon dont s'est déroulé
le dernier grand prix de la saison le
brouillard la pluie ont faussé le duel
hunt l'aude depuis deux mois et demi à
l'autrichien fait preuve d'un tel
courage pour revenir
premier plan après son accident
nürburging que l'on avait presque oublié
qu'ils n'étaient encore en fait qu'un
convalescent brûlée au visage les
paupières figé ne pouvant se fermer
l'autrichien ne peux dormir normalement
par ailleurs son acuité visuelle et di
mino alors vu les conditions
métérologiques dès le départ du grand
prix
lauda a su qu'il allait perdre senti
comme vous l'avez vue sur ces images au
deuxième tour il arrête sa ferrari au
stand la mécanique n'est pas responsable
non mais lauda abandonne incapable de
jouer plus longtemps les héros mines et
physiquement il a peur oui peur et donc
il ne veut plus perdre prendre de
risques il est vaincu le pilote lauda
n'est pas en cause c'est l'homme qui a
atteint ses limites
à l'impossible nul n'est tenu
consécration du nouveau maître de la
chinois coiffant toute petite erreur
avant de voir les titres de revoir les
tripes exactement de l'actualité lien un
dossier dans ce journal
les élections consulaires cela ne vous
dit peut-être pas grand chose pourtant
dès demain un million cinq cent mille
entreprises vont élire leurs
représentants aux chambres de commerce
et d'industrie c'est-à-dire 2230
exactement véritables députés du
commerce et de l'industrie il s'agit du
renouvellement de la moitié des sièges
des chambres de commerce dont le rôle
n'est pas toujours lui non plus très
connu du grand public c'est pourquoi
nous avons voulu ce soir vous montrer
l'activité de l'une des plus importantes
chambres de commerce et d'industrie de
france celle de marseille son activité
et son rôle très important dans
l'économie régionale
499 marseille vient de réintégrer le
royaume de france pour développer
l'économie de la ville et du port
henry cap approuve la création de quatre
députés du commerce c'est la première
modalités de la chambre de commerce de
marcel 1976 la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie gère aujourd'hui un budget
de 150 millions
l'aéroport de marignane le deuxième de
france par le nom des passagers est
l'une de ses activités
chargé de représenter les industriels
les commerçants et les prestataires de
services auprès des pouvoirs publics
elle doit aussi aider l'économie
régionale cette zone industrielle à
vitrolles en est un autre exemple
ainsi la chambre de commerce n'est plus
une aimable assemblée de notables
elle est devenue avec la municipalité et
le port autonome
l'un des trois principaux pouvoirs
économiques de la région
c'est un pouvoir important mais que je
situe dans l'union avec les élus
politiques
car si nous voulons faire quelque chose
d'efficace il faudra faire travailler en
parfaite union
je ne vois pas comment nous pourrions
faire autres morts donc c'est une
affaire d'hommes
un pouvoir économique mais c'est aussi
finalement un pouvoir politique
je ne le pense pas parce que politique
économique si vous le voulez mais
politique au sens où vous l'entendez
certainement pas nos motivations ne sont
pas les mêmes
c'est pourquoi nous nous complétons
parfaitement bien avec les élus
politiques
c'est dans le domaine de la formation
que la chambre apporte sans doute les
services les plus concrets ont relevé
dans l'eau un vrai prenant servic 1 et
dira plus qu'à me suivre
exemple cette école de plongée unique au
monde qui forment 200 plongeurs en eaux
profondes
chaque année mais les exemples il y en a
d'autres car plus de 50% du budget de la
chambre est consacrée à cette formation
il y a ainsi l'enseignement technique
supérieure avec les écoles d'ingénieurs
de commerce et de chimie et puis il y à
la maison de la formation continue je
vous propose la méthode suivant métal
classique qui quoi où quand comment
combien et à chaque séquence pourquoi là
par exemple
quatre mille cinq cents commerçants ou
travailleurs de l'industrie sont venus
l'année dernière utiliser les méthodes
les plus modernes pour se recycler ou se
perfectionner et pourtant toutes ces
possibilités qu'offre la chambre de
commerce sont souvent mal connues même
des connaissances
je travaille pas mal avec eux et les
points de vue formation dont deux
étalagiste on accueille aussi des
stagiaires de la formation continue mais
qui a vraiment à peu près tout le
service à chambre de commerce que je
connais parce que vous êtes au courant
des activités de la chambre de commerce
et d'industrie de marseille
non vous ne savez pas ce que fait la
chambre de commerce
grosso modo oui mais enfin je sais
qu'elle a un rôle économique de la ville
de marseille pour la ville de man c'est
ma part facebook je sais que j'avais été
en contact avec eux déjà menés ils ont
cherché à vous contacter je pense que
elle va s'occuper
côté industriel parce que c'est ça me le
moteur de fin de toute l'activité
qui profite le plus des services
proposés les industriels ou les
commerçants c'est une vieille querelle
que connaissent toutes les chambres en
france à marseille on se défend en tout
cas de privilégier l'un ou l'autre nous
apportons par nos assistants techniques
au commerce
une aide aux commerçants et ensuite par
nos assistants techniques à l'industrie
notre aide aux industriels mais il faut
reconnaître qu'il y à des programmes
comme par conséquent il ya aucune
différence
l'assistance peut changer de nature
parfois mais le niveau est le même que
les intérêts d'un petit commerçant et
d'un gros industriels sont quand même
très différent
ils sont différents mais il y a des
points communs ne serait ce que dans la
gestion et le service que nous apportons
qui a compte de ces différences
industriels commerçants prestataires de
services participent tous au financement
des chambres par la taxe professionnelle
il participe au fonctionnement à travers
les délégués qu'ils élisent lundi à
marseille comme ailleurs leur bulletin
de vote indiquera l'orientation qu'il
souhaite donner à toutes ces activités
il n'a pas fait très très beau
aujourd'hui sur la majeure partie de la
france excepté à marseille et sur le
sud-est demain sur la moitié la moitié
sud pardon le temps sera couvert avec
des pluies orageuses et souvent
abondantes sur les cévennes et les alpes
il y aura de la neige à partir de 15
cents mètres dans les pyrénées et de
2000 mètres dans les alpes et puis la
météo prévoit des vents de sud-est sur
la corse et la côte d'azur et de
nordouest sur le golfe du lion et le
golfe de gascogne dans le nord de la
france
le temps sera variable avec des
éclaircies mais aussi quelques averses
en particulier de la manche au nord du
massif central avec toute la rédaction
d'antenne 2 je vous remercie d'avoir
suivi ce journal bonsoir vous avez
rendez vous avec maurice schumann dans
un instant mais d'abord le rappel des
principaux titres de l'actualité c'est
maintenant
les traditionalistes de monseigneur
lefebvre se manifeste à l'assemblée des
évêques pour jean lecanu et la lutte
contre l'inflation doit être le premier
objectif le dernier journal d'antenne 2
à 23h05